three days of exercises involving
Chinese military aircraft and warships
have heightened tensions across the
Taiwan Strait Beijing says the drills
simulated Precision attacks against
Targets on the island and its complete
encirclement and involved the Shandong
aircraft carrier
Taiwan scrambled fighter jets in
response it follows last week's visit by
taiwan's President saying when to
California where she met U.S Speaker of
the House Kevin McCarthy Beijing says
the exercise is send a clear warning to
any fractional forces in Taiwan who may
be seeking full Independence for the
island which China regards as a
breakaway province
foreign
warning to the provocative activities of
Taiwan Independence successionist forces
and collusion with the external forces
and a necessary move to safeguard
National sovereignty and territorial
Integrity taiwan's defense Ministry has
condemned the drills accusing Beijing of
destabilizing the region and declaring
the island will continue with its own
system of government
their Armed Forces will uphold our
sovereignty and maintain our national
security in a composed rational and
thoughtful manner with presidential
elections next year the current
administration's policy of keeping China
at a distance is popular among many
Taiwanese
wanting to Annex Taiwan is quite a weird
thing it's like if I were to say a place
that I want to have and then just say
that I want to Annex it that doesn't
sound very reasonable historically there
were some connections but that is not to
say that Taiwan belongs to China
most Ordinary People probably aren't
afraid of the drills with the main
reason being that everyone thinks that
China won't start of all China considers
Taiwan part of its territory and has not
ruled out using Force to take it Rob
McBride Al Jazeera